hello and just stay awake this late
Islam my name is Mike Sinclair and I'm
interested natural user interfaces
specifically haptics and I work in Ken's
group epic group and I'm gonna show you
a few projects that I've been recently
involved in in Microsoft Research and
those are a few my collaborators so over
the past few years
needles say I'm like many of you easily
amused and that's part of the attributes
and some of the misgivings of my
behavior but here are some projects that
have resulted in various publications
patents collaborations a little entree
into products and whatnot but I keep
real busy we have a great hardware rapid
prototyping shop right across the the
atrium come and visit us later today
you're welcome to look around and of a
of some of those last couple of years
I've been interested haptics which is
the sense of touch
learning to exploit physical phenomena
for sensors and actuators some are
existing today and some are just
postulated back in 2015
published and built a device called
touch mover it was essentially a
computer display on a robotic arm you
touched it it monitored the force of
your touch and it would respond to the
force of touch and add auxilary forces
to that to make you think you're
actually pushing blocks over or or
touching tissue and whatnot
in 2016 we did a thing called normal
touch where was a small device you put a
finger on and it replicated when you
came close or touched a virtual surface
your finger would be touching this pad
that would replicate the instantaneous
surface normal so you could actually
feel contours of non-existing objects
that do you that you would also see in
the VR headset
and also in 2016 we did texture touch
and that was an array of 4x4 pins that
would in real time come out and
replicate the texture of the surface
that you were trying to attach virtual
surface 2017 claw that was an active
device had a servo in it stuck your
finger and the little hole in there and
you could reach out and actually touch
or pinch devices and with the right kind
of feedback those those of you or having
any background you know you can get just
about any kind of kinesthetic touch that
you want it's soft hard compliant
nonlinear like when you push a button in
2018 after a bunch of captive audiences
by our product groups we say all right
we'd like to get some of this into
products or at least have the semblance
of you're interested getting in popular
products and get away from the buzzers
in haptics today which is a very
conservative approach and they say okay
it it can't be breakable it has to be
easily producible low-cost etc etc etc
so we came up with a device called
torque which actually doesn't move but
it does give you the sense of touch it
it measures human force you've got a a
2d touchpad under the thumb and between
that and the force sensed on the other
two fingers you can do micro minute
manipulations especially if you have
visual override to actually see your
fingers moving when they're actually not
except for your thumb and in a little
over a little under two weeks we'll
present what's called Captain Crunch
it's a resistive approach can you use
brakes to let the user put the
mechanical energy into the system and
this device just resists the the users
touch and feel so we were weighing the
attributes of active versus resistance
haptics active say being driven by a
motor or resistive being resisted by a
brake and that's what capstan touches
where instead of putting a lot of power
into a motor
and having that motor respond to force
feedback like in force sensors the the
brake would through its it's a
mechanical gain and very low-power input
would resist the human forces kinematic
on the handheld device and those of you
who have ever been sailing know what
what good a capstan can do it can hold
forces of thousands of pounds of tension
with just two fingers so if there's a
lot of mechanical gain and if you do it
right and choose the right materials you
can get actually a linear force break
that can go from zero to two maximum
force the problem with brakes is there
there's no compliance there's no
squishiness so we actually added a
capstan based clutch with a spring in it
and we believe with with the latest of
incarnation we can actually embody high
resistive force low resistive force
along with compliance along with
nonlinear with hysteresis attributes and
there's a picture of our present looks a
little present device Captain Crunch
looks a little complicated as big
understand that probably hard to get
into products but the eventual goal is
to put all that inside of a handle that
you hold and it resists the forces of of
your four fingers against your thumb and
the equation there on the the right was
the tell-tale or that the gain is is
multiplied by an X exponential that
relies on the the number of wraps of the
cord and the particular friction of the
court against the capstan so we exploit
that with very low low cost and fast
actuators less than two milliseconds we
can get very very fast response at human
scale forces in the in the actual
controller so so that's it
sorry for the creepy slide but
I didn't think they were happy enough
they're in their careers now and they're
as happy as most of us are here playing
around thank you the different like
modalities of haptics that you guys are
interested in so it seemed like a lot of
this stuff was mechanical haptics yes
I'm just wondering if you guys are
interested any of the free space optics
work that had been done in the car I'm
sorry what any of the free space
haptics work that has done like yes like
ultrasonic ultrasonic very interested
very creative use of energy propagated
through ultrasonics they're to me right
now they're a little subtle it's very
difficult when I first FET felt or
experienced that I had to let everybody
in the room be quiet
so I could actually feel it and I
couldn't quite feel that was a flower in
my hand it was something there and that
was very very subtle same thing with
Tesla Touch which when you scrub your
finger across a screen you actually feel
friction being modulated again very
subtle not human scale forces so you're
talking about hundreds of a Newton where
we operate at up to 20 to 30 Newton's so
that's what I'm looking for is in
natural haptics does it actually
replicate human scale forces but yes
that's a I really like some of the
creativity is going on in free space
haptics thank you
[Applause]
you